credit where credit's due I'm used to
seeing Early Access gushing when it
comes to Early Access for movies and it
absolutely happened with the flash but
I've never seen Tom Cruise get in on it
that's next level it's like they're
playing chess over there Warner Brothers
marketing
[Music]
stragglers in the in the old DC Universe
before it's the new James Gunn verse we
got Aquaman after this then Blue Beetle
wait a minute strike that
reverse it I think that's then it's done
so in the flash Barry Allen once again
played by Ezra Miller he basically comes
to the point where he's like hey you
guys ever read that comic book
Flashpoint thus a new timeline is
created so you have the tale of two
berries Supergirl and Michael Keaton's
Batman they all team up because they
gotta they gotta stop General Zod all
right starting out Ezra Miller as Barry
Allen well actually there's two Barry
Allen's in here but there's this anyhow
Ezra Miller's Vibe never felt like Barry
Allen to me totally worked in an
ensemble capacity Zack Snyder's Justice
League it's like they knew that and they
were like great let's make this an
ensemble film but I liked Ezra Miller as
The Flash in this movie more than I have
ever liked Ezra Miller as the flash they
actually do a very clever thing having
Barry Allen and Barry Allen hang out
together because one is the older
essentially post Justice League flash
hanging out with a younger flash who
just got his powers I gotta say with
younger Barry Allen I was like he is
obnoxious but it's kind of the point
there's an arc of growth with him one we
didn't really really get with Barry
Allen before because they were like oh
The Flash
here's Justice League what about the
Standalone origin movie The what so we
never got to see that Barry Allen just
got his powers and he's coming into his
own kind of Arc we see a bit of it here
a version of it anyway but they play on
Barry Allen being annoyed by a younger
version of himself because that's we all
would be if we are our own worst critics
imagine hanging out with a version of
you that's 10 years younger than you are
now a cool concept that's in this movie
I appreciate that we've seen one actor
play two roles in the same scene in a
movie before there's something about
this it seemed to mix so much better
there are scenes where Barry will pick
up Barry face through a wall and then
put Barry back down and I'm like
this is the same actor great work
blending the faces of the bodies however
they did it it looks phenomenal which is
ironic because there's some CGI in this
movie it's iffy as [__] it's actually
one of the main reasons I didn't review
this movie immediately after I saw it in
cinema con because I was like that's
some of that CGI was iffy maybe it's not
polished yet after watching it now I'm
like that if he CGI well it's still
there granny they're doing some Grand
scale things with the CGI in here and it
does look cool but when you see CGI
faces and CGI people in these scenes
it's
uncanny valley is the thing now it's not
just the tale of two berries you also
have Supergirl and Michael Keaton Batman
I thought Supergirl worked great yes she
does not feel like Cara zarel that you
might know or be used to but that's kind
of the point here she's not supposed to
keep in mind you are dealing with an
alternate timeline and alternate
universe so I mean proceed accordingly
and whatever that might mean for you but
if she did feel like you know super girl
and it wouldn't work for this Arc and
the big guns Michael Keaton's Batman I
say big guns because it is kind of funny
that the big guns in The Flash movie
feels like Batman not the flash I mean
when I first saw the first trailer it
felt like they were like
um let's have Michael Keaton's Batman in
here so so people go to it after seeing
the movie it still does feel like that
like I said Ezra Miller absolutely
surprised me in here but it still feels
like that was the intent this movie is
mixed with moments where it absolutely
works and he is a scene stealer it's
also him in tandem with that Danny
Elfman score that we know and love I
mean when Michael hitting Batman's doing
his thing
you can't help it there there's a
reaction in the brain and the smile
starts happening on the other hand there
were some heavy-handed callbacks where I
was like that just it feels weird like
it's great to hear Michael Keaton Batman
be like my Batman at least want the
flash to be like I know
I know you're Batman you know I know
you're Batman that's why we're here why
else who are you talking to right now is
there a camera we don't see oh my gosh
are we in a movie is
heavy-handed callbacks in Nostalgia Bay
you do expect it to a degree it is a
little unfortunate this is coming out so
soon after across the spider verse and
that did it very well it was a
Multiverse movie that had Easter eggs
and callbacks that were very well
integrated and woven into the plot felt
organic it's like this movie was like we
don't know how to do that in fact we
didn't know that movie was gonna [__]
know how to do it that well either I
just say I'm Batman say you want to get
nuts let's get nuts none of it will make
any sense but you said it in the old
movie and by God you gotta say it here
there were a couple of edits that had me
scratching my head too one in particular
they had to get out of this building
they didn't know how there were guards
and then they just they get out somehow
it's like what are we gonna do very next
scene one Barry's holding the other
Barry over his shoulder you know like
the arm over the shoulder helping him
get into the apartment like all right
we're back now and yes this movie is
around two hours 20 minutes long
and it feels a bit too long but this is
a Flash movie how is the speed the
speed's absolutely satisfying it feels
fast and it hits hard there are some
effects they do in this movie that
enhance the feeling of speed and punch
that I didn't see in the Justice League
so I appreciate that new tactics the
speed has to be felt in a Flash movie
and I felt it what really landed what
hooked me in this movie is the emotional
scenes between Barry and his mom or
involving Barry and his mom there's a
really heartfelt family Dynamic going on
in here and I felt it it's kind of funny
you think Michael Keaton Batman is going
to be the thing that hooks you and
essentially why he was here to hook you
and really it's glad he was in it I
don't think the movie needed him to be
in it it's also it's a funny movie some
jokes really land there are some
reference jokes that I actually loved
other jokes I was like
that's a bit much but in the end the
important thing is I enjoyed the flash
it's a fun comic book film that uses its
premise to push the story of Barry Allen
forward while also having a character
that's essentially the origin story for
this Barry Allen in this universe that
we never got it is yet again another
Multiverse movie in the comic book movie
genre that is chock full of Multiverse
movies but it's one that I had fun with
and unlike some other recent DC Universe
movies I wasn't left with that feeling
of well what does it matter it's being
undone anyway maybe it's because it's
the Flash and that in and of itself
makes it feel like Canon but I think
more importantly it's a movie I had fun
with that's the important thing if I'm
watching a movie in which this universe
is gonna disappear anyway because
someone else has taken over the creative
process at least making a movie where
I'm having fun in it with solid hitting
emotional beats yeah that helps too I
had myself a fun time no alcohol
required all right so the flash it's not
out quite yet but for the sake of if
you're watching this video after the
movie comes out have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's a good
Flash comic book what are some good arcs
out there like some new ones whatever it
is whatever comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]